the Joe Rogan experience I was ringside
when Deontay Wilder knocked out Brazil I
was all that with my brother bro dude
bro dude that guy
it's a and I've been a lot of I've been
in fights I've been knocked out I've
been at UFC fights where dudes get
knocked out I have never in my life
heard someone get knocked out like that
my brother goes oh my god my brother's a
bra dude oh my god
and where they satisfy his family mmm
and it ruined it for me because you
can't cheer I saw the wife I just I just
went oh my god I didn't cheer I wouldn't
cheer anyway but I was just like oh my
god and this the funniest part is my boy
at the Brian Brian daily at Showtime
just so in between rounds um probably
two and three Jim Gray is gonna come an
interview about your Showtime special
you Oh that'd be cool they tell me the
day before so you get this nice outfit
my brother's work did you really think
he was gonna get to go under for I
didn't think one round but I thought
there was a chance they sent me there
Jim gay he's gonna come then do so I
might get out of here huh good idea John
dude I'm telling you man he something so
special man yeah he's such a good dude
you've never done it was amazing he's
great we had a great time
how passion is he he's a sweetheart it
was like a really nice guy that was my
problem with him going oh I want to
murder this guy I want to kill this guy
I don't want exercise my right like I
expect that from these for lack of
better term these animals these guys
weren't at your level but he's such a
good person like God dude don't do that
because they can paint you into that box
I believe that's gonna just go away but
it's gone that's gone it's gone his
performance is so spectacular I think it
goes away but I think it's also that was
his legitimate mindset at that time you
know I mean that guy if you listen to my
podcast when I interviewed him talked
about how he got into boxing because of
his daughter he stood on yours as well
talk about that that's a special person
man I mean he became a bronze medalist
in the Olympics after a year and a half
of boxing that's insane especially
that's insane man you got to imagine he
was bought defusing a year and a half of
boxing and he's entered into Olympics
he's going to be having matches against
guys who have 10 years experience easy
hundreds of
fights 105 hundreds and he's got like
virtually no experience and he's not
like the slickest guy in the world
either so he has to be able to take a
shot but he's got two giant advantages
huge reach and ridiculous power and I
think lettuce isn't because yeah and I
think because of the fact that he's not
a big heavyweight I don't think he gets
as tired as they do I agree Thank You
Jaime this might have the heaviest he's
ever been he came in at 223 and what did
he really I went that's interesting
because usually to 14 to 13 he punches
so hard man he's the scariest
heavyweight knockout artist since Mike
Tyson 100% when he was walking out were
you great when he's walking I looked up
my brother I went I went you know how
you feel right now you goosebumps I want
to imagine being on Mike Tyson fighting
in his prime how that [ __ ] crowd must
have felt yeah because when he was
walking out I felt so bad for Brazil cuz
I'm like we're Nexus family I'm like
he's such an underdog he's gonna get
knocked out just we're dealing I think
we're gonna see that with Deontay Wilder
I think Deontay Wilder Zanu Mike Tyson
100% I think he's the new money is that
hard in what's instrument him is
everyone gives me [ __ ] like you're such
a Hummer if you work for a Showtime no
no here's the thing about that Joe what
people don't realize is Deonte while his
fights are on Showtime he's an
independent contractor he doesn't have a
promoter
he's his team you know the soda zone
after him hundreds of millions of
dollars same as they offered Joshua nel
he turned it down
dan you know why because he wants he
wants to fight Joshua's fight fury goes
well if I'm with them that's gonna limit
me fight inferior Joshua if I'm
independent I can fight Joshua I can
fight Wilder if I was a Wilder I'd be
terrified right now why do you think
they I mean not Wilder rather a fury
Joshua or fewer I'd be terrified of that
my that mindset lazier fights yeah but
he's the scariest fight of all time in
the [ __ ] 12th round when he cracks
Tyson Fury drops him like that like in
the 12th round he still has this
ridiculous power and he's only getting
better but I think what happens is him
it's more likely especially looking at
the way promoters work you didn't get
Joshua verse Wilder before you get fury
oh I think so oh yeah I'm fine I want
all three of them I do
thank these [ __ ] oh it these [ __ ] it's
context remember these sucks
oh it to boxing yes to the like see a
box and fight each other well it's one
of those rare moments in the heavyweight
division where you have three
unbelievably compelling guys and then
one of them was a former champion who by
the way the last fight was a draw and I
thought he should have won a decision so
if you look at it I thought he should
want a decision but I agree with the
results until this is what's real
squirrely creech because the way Wilder
heard him dropped him and then knocked
him down and almost had him flatlined in
the 12th and if you go over the actual
count the actual ten count from one to
ten from the time he dropped which is
not what Tyson Fury's jobs is Tyson
Fury's jobs get up in the referee says
nine and he did that he did that but if
you go by an actual class eleven or
twelve in it yeah you go buy an actual
clock about eleven yeah it's Hyson fury
lost that ten count
but fury one of the rounds yes sir he
one more round hands down yep oxen yeah
right that count was longer than ten
yeah he not he should have if you were
just going by ten seconds Deontay Wilder
has a real argument that she should have
won by knockout here's the thing that's
why I like the drug yes that's why the
draw fantastic cool
run it back let's get a clear winner
yeah and then Joshua who's this animal
out there who's just this [ __ ] he's
so damn good he's like honestly though
what the [ __ ] is a ten count for if it's
not 10 seconds why is the referee human
error count human error there should be
in every [ __ ] corner every corner
wherever the fight is there should be a
clock and then when someone goes down
someone else not the referee hits that
button second one well you can really do
three four five six could you go one two
three four yeah five yeah but he goes
wow that he's jacked up with adrenaline
there's a huge knock out the crowd I
want a guy to get up you might want to
gotta get up you might want to help but
has anybody take extra time to rub the
gloves on his chest ask him a couple
questions okay good and they grab
towards me loss towards me what's
today's date you could do all that [ __ ]
you can give them a little bit of a
break do you like the human air part
like saying with baseball like the amps
they [ __ ] up no all the time
[Applause]